[Music]
foreign
Andy Goodman's general manager and VP of
engineering for databases at Google
cloud and I'm excited to share with you
what's next for Builders and data
engineers at Google Cloud our mission is
to accelerate every organization's
ability to digitally transform
and a large part of that is helping
customers innovate faster with the
unified open and intelligent data
platform
we do this by focusing on four key areas
first a unified and integrated data
Cloud for all your data
second a commitment to openness
leveraging open source and Open
Standards
third infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workflows
and lastly empowering Builders to be
more productive and impactful
let's start with the first Focus area
creating a unified and integrated data
Cloud if you're operational and
analytical data
the way we've built our core services
such as Cloud spanner bigtable alloy DB
MPEG query is truly differentiated
these Services leverage Google's common
infrastructure which is unique in the
industry
our highly scalable distributed storage
system
are disaggregated compute and storage
and are high performance google-owned
Global networking allow us to provide
industry leading tightly integrated
operational and analytical data services
building on this customers need to have
easy movement of data within the data
cloud
we heard you and that's why we announced
in preview data stream for bigquery
data stream for bigquery provides easy
replication of data from operational
database sources such as lodb postgres
MySQL and Oracle directly into bigquery
this is special because we worked
closely with the bigquery team to
develop an optimized integration to
replicate database updates in real time
at very low latency
setup is just a few simple clicks to
continue on this theme of easy data
replication from operational databases
for use cases like analytics event-based
architectures compliance or archival
we're announcing today in preview
bigtable change streams
this capability joins our already
existing recently launched spanner
change streams
with chain streams you can check rights
updates and delete so that they can be
replicated to Downstream systems in real
time the second Focus area is our
continued commitment to open source and
Open Standards for increased flexibility
and portability without vendor lock-in
we offer many services that are fully
compatible with the most popular open
source engines such as MySQL postgres
and redis postgres an open source
database has emerged as the leading
alternative to Legacy proprietary
databases because of its Rich
functionality ecosystem extensions and
Enterprise readiness
it's not surprising that millions of
users across Industries have adopted
postgres
we're focused on making Google Cloud the
best place to run your postgres
workloads
we offer you not one not two but three
fully managed services that support the
postgres interface
first Cloud SQL for postgres it is our
Enterprise ready fully managed
relational database service
you get the same experience of Open
Source postgres with the strong
manageability availability and security
capabilities of cloud SQL
and you can use the same service apis to
also manage your MySQL and SQL Server
databases
second alloy DBS are fully managed
postgres compatible database service
ready for your top tier workloads and
for modernizing your legacy proprietary
databases in the cloud
in our performance tests alloyodb is
more than four times faster than open
source postgres and two times faster
than Amazon's comparable postgres
compatible service for transactional
workloads
it also delivers up to 100 times faster
analytical queries than standard
postgres
and open isn't just about our technology
it's also about developing an open
ecosystem of Partners alloy DB already
integrates with many leading Technology
Solutions and has a fast-growing
ecosystem of partners with expertise
ready to support your deployments and
finally we've also added a postgres
interface for spanner our transformative
relational database with unlimited
global scale strong external consistency
and up to five nines availability
with the postgres interface for spanner
developers can take advantage of
familiar tools and skills from the
postgres ecosystem
and to further democratize access to
spanner we recently announced a free
trial to give Builders an easy way to
try out spanner at no cost
get started building with spanner today
the third Focus area is around how we
are infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workloads we use Ai and ml
across our database Technologies to make
our services more intelligent
capabilities such as Cloud SQL cost
recommenders and alloy DB autopilot
enable dbas and devops teams to manage
performance and capacity for large
fleets of databases
in addition to infusing Ai and ml into
our databases we're providing
integration with vertex AI our Ai and ml
platform to enable model inferencing
directly within the database transaction
I'm therefore excited to announce today
in preview the integration of vertex AI
with spanner
you can now use a SQL query in spanner
to call a model and vertex AI
with this integration both alloy DB and
now spanner can simply call vertex AI
models using SQL in operational
transactions allowing data scientists to
build their models easily in vertex Ai
and developers to access these models
using the SQL query language our final
Focus area is around empowering Builders
to be more productive with Innovative
one-of-a-kind developer experiences
we've introduced Cloud SQL query
insights for postgres and MySQL in
addition we make Cloud SQL cost
recommenders generally available and
introduce postgres system insights in
preview
today we're excited to announce the
preview of security and performance
recommenders for cloud SQL so now let's
hear from Scott Wong VP of
infrastructure at Credit Karma to learn
how they've reduced operational burden
and cost with Google's data cloud
Scott welcome
we're glad to have you here today
thanks for having me Andy excited to be
here
tell me Scott who is Credit Karma and
why did you choose Google Cloud
in 2007 Credit Karma was founded during
the last housing crisis with a mission
to be the consumer technology platform
focused on helping our members Achieve
Financial progress and over the last 15
years we've really built this around
free credit scores providing over 4
billion credit scores to our consumers
across the US UK and Canada and today
nearly 130 million members use our
product but Financial progress term our
members means much more than just credit
reports we are the go-to destination for
everything related to financial goals
and to provide this we provide
personalized data-driven insights to our
members to feel more confident about
their major money decisions and at the
center of these insights is our data
models and Data Systems all being
powered by Google cloud services today
how are you using Google's data Cloud
today for your key use cases and what
are some business benefits you've
achieved by moving to Google Cloud one
we really focus on making our data
scientists as efficient as possible
and that meant simplifying access to our
users feature store as well as deploying
their models as quickly as possible
to give you some extent of scale today
we deploy over 700 models a week as
opposed to pre-cloud it was almost 10 a
quarter
additionally in experimentation we do
over 7x more experiments today than we
did before cloud
and with the help of bigtable and
bigquery we have 10x more features
deployed daily through our batch data
these gains can be attributed to what we
call our unified model training powered
by bigquery bigtable dataflow and
Google's AI platform
thank you so much for that conversation
Scott I really appreciate you joining us
today
thank you for having me Andy and I
enjoyed being part of Google next
as you can see from always spoken about
today the future of data has endless
possibilities
tune in to all our sessions and next for
more details on the announcements you
heard today
thank you enjoy the rest of next
[Music]